vamos ahora en directo a Uruguay porque
la crisis
hídrica no da tregua este país
sudamericano que está atravesando
recordemos hace ya más de un mes una
sequía que es histórica y que
desencadenó en una escasez de agua sin
precedente un escenario que llevó al
gobierno a decretar la emergencia
hídrica en Montevideo y en el área
metropolitana donde millones de personas
podrían quedarse sin agua dulce para
abordar este tema saludamos a Karina
dalmaz corresponsal de Franz 24 en
español en Uruguay Karina muy buenas
noches bienvenida directo a América
contanos Cuál es la situación por estos
momentos En qué estado se encuentran las
reservas de agua sobre todo y qué
escenarios se proyecta a futuro
Hola Santiago Así es como tú lo
mencionabas Es realmente un escenario
muy crítico De hecho hace pocas horas el
presidente de la república Luis lacalle
en conferencia de prensa le dijo a la
población que si no llueve y en grandes
cantidades en los próximos días lo cual
no está en los pronósticos del clima va
a haber un periodo de tiempo en los
cuales el agua que llega a los hogares Y
por supuesto a la industria también va
no va a ser bebible esto se debe a que
bueno el gobierno está atravesando una
situación crítica en cuanto a la sequía
lo mencionaba el próximo el propio
presidente de la calle Pou que es una
sequía que no se ha visto de tal
magnitud en los últimos 70 años las
medidas que decidió el gobierno entre
ellas es una obra que se Está realizando
en el río San José y esta obra Todavía
falta un par de semanas para poder ser
concluida y pali un poco el tema de la
situación del agua potable tú lo
mencionabas recién el tema es que el
agua dulce se agotó prácticamente las
imágenes son desgarradoras en lo que es
toda la Represa de verediro que
justamente provee agua para la capital
de Uruguay Montevideo donde más de un
millón y medio de personas casi dos
millones de personas están viendo
afectadas por lo mismo es un agua que el
presidente hizo bueno los próximos días
no va a ser bebible si bien está dentro
de los parámetros que el Ministerio de
salud pública le ha dicho algo gobierno
que debe mantenerse muchos de estos
millones de montevideanos Dicen que el
agua ya no es de Biblia hace semanas por
varios motivos uno por la cantidad de
sodio que tiene la misma
por el hecho de que se está utilizando
más agua del río de la plata Que agua
dulce y bueno en la ecuación el agua que
llega Es realmente de un sabor muy
molesto Para que se consuma y por otro
lado algo Bastante más preocupante que
es los trialometanos que contiene esta
agua que está llegando a los hogares
debido a que el proceso para desinfectar
la misma se le aplica entre otras cosas
más cloro y está llegando estos
elementos que según el propio Ministerio
de salud pública le recomienda por
ejemplo a las embarazadas a no consumir
la misma hubo Tuvo una polémica en
cuanto a la evidencia científica al
respecto Lo cierto es que mucha
población está preocupada lo mismo
también el Ministerio de salud pública
aconsejó para las problemas de las
personas con problemas renales y con
problemas de cardiopatías justamente por
el sodio Esto está ocurriendo también
que está generando otros efectos que son
los efectos económicos a nivel doméstico
en las casas muchísimas de los
calentadores de agua dejaron de
funcionar se rompen por la cantidad de
sal y también muchísimas industrias
incluso han puesto en licencia a sus
trabajadores porque han tenido que
paralizar sus producciones debido al
cantidad de sodio y también la cantidad
de agua que reci